game pass hits a new milestone and gets
even more games this month plus halo
infinite has another event
the next wave of xbox game pass titles
for january has been confirmed following
a leak these include danganronpa trigger
happy havoc anniversary edition taiko no
tetsujin the drum master the hitman
trilogy nobody saves the world paparazzi
rainbow six extraction windjammers two
rainbow succeeds deluxe edition and
death's door which i cannot recommend
enough it was my personal game of the
year for 2021 and do yourself a favor
play this game january 2022 has already
been a massive month for game pass with
mass effect legendary edition spelunky 2
and the outer wilds landing on the
subscription service earlier this month
and the game pass news doesn't stop
there because the service hit a new
milestone recently microsoft announced
that xbox game pass now has more than 25
million subscribers globally a number
that i'm sure will skyrocket if and when
activision blizzard games like call of
duty and overwatch show up on the
service but devante why would those
games show up on game pass well if you
somehow didn't hear xbox acquired
activision blizzard for nearly 70
billion dollars and if you want to know
more about it and what's happening with
bobby kotek you can check out our
previous news video for a good summary
of the deal
in other xbox news halo infinite's
multiplayer is getting another free
event the event called cyber showdown
kicks off today january 18th there are
10 rewards for this event that span
multiple areas of the game's
customization menus including a new
spartan helmet accessory that gives
players a multi-colored hologram mohawk
as well as vibrant new weapon and armor
coatings that are sure to make you stand
out in every multiplayer battle this
event will work similar to previous ones
where players will need to complete
specific event challenges in order to
progress in the free event pass however
these challenges need to be completed in
the event's special game mode attrition
in this game mode players will go into a
down state before death and can either
be finished off by enemies or revived by
allies points aren't accrued unless
players are killed from their down state
there's also an xbox achievement that
can be earned in this mode as it
requires you to revive down teammates
the event is set to end on january 31st
meaning you'll have just under two weeks
to nab every reward before they
disappear like the winter contingency
event this would appear to be the only
window during which you can unlock these
rewards but 343 may rethink those plans
later so your homework for this video
isn't to leave a comment or anything
it's just to go play death's door all
right there's going to be a pop quiz on
it tomorrow so make sure you're ready
[Music]
you